well so just uh to kind of like level up
a bit
for the topic i think there's actually
some gem here uh for all companies
yeah and it's something i'm thinking a
lot about is in terms of design
yeah so for figma one thing we do in our
product process is try to just like get
features out in front of the community
as fast as we can
not only not to just ship them but also
just to get the feedback on them right
but people can think of that if you
change stuff
well it's less about managing people
being upset and more about
getting to the point where you're
building the best product yes um and i
think that the thing that's going to be
really interesting here so one thing
we're trying to do with figma is
talk more and create more of a movement
around what we're calling open design
and what is open design so basically
open design is like a few different
things one is how do i become
in my organization how do i design do
design more openly
uh but also in the context of the world
how do i have a design process that my
users
my customers can actually be part of
right um
transparency isn't the downside to that
being transparent that you're educating
your competitors
uh it depends right like another way to
think about it is like
you're actually becoming more
anti-fragile you're creating a community
that's more loyal to you
right um and you're working with them
and partnering with them for the long
term
to make the product that's best for them
explain to people what antifragile means
it's kind of like yeah i actually don't
know if i like a good
one-line definition to you um well it's
to leib's idea that there
are certain uh there's
there are systems that do better
in times of crises or with volatility
yep so if something is volatile like the
moment now
what does better in volatility so are
there cities in the world or
people who think and who are designed
for a volatile situation so instead of
being fragile
they're the opposite of fragile which is
not being necessarily strong it's being
resilient and strong in the face of a
chaotic situation right a great
definition yeah
i think that's the way he defines i've
always tried to i
and you know what i i in when i i've
i've listened to that book twice
and every time i listen to it i get more
from it i kind of feel like his books
i think you kind of get them on the
third reading huh
sorry if more times then yeah same with
black swan i mean i think if you
are living through what we're living
through right now the black swan is
something you really need to understand
which is just out of left field your
whole world can get turned upside down